yoth aussi squeeze aujourd'hui on se
trompe sur ipad pour un petit jeu qui
s'appelle la gare poigne au alors
j'espère que bon vous m'avez grille et
j'ai envie de refaire une vidéo sur ce
jeune homme il fallait que ce soit prêté
à lorient la version ipad ok c'est parti
on va s'appeler directement une grande
violence je te baise isi c'est
l'arrogance bien via l es l et ouvre le
bal ouvrent le bal là on est 54e
tout va bien oh my god oh oh oh what
japonais howard saponines what's
happening au haut et au stella dégage
postulat des gages aux la lune et le feu
au les [ __ ] au lit mais les mecs qui
prennent à 3 comme ça est toutefois
toujours tu ne t'es pas comme moi je te
prends frontale comme ça direct direct
qui jouent au foot c'est quoi zaouïa y
est
moi je me fais robbie sauf à dont il y a
[Musique]
emportez votre char avec vous étendez
votre linge sur le canon du char au
moulin jetons sur autre chose tu vois ce
que je veux dire ah ah t'es mort ah t'es
mort atchoum 2 d'un couple et âge oh mon
dieu j'ai le sien ce pétage fois la luge
et le manger et voilà qu'en des
allemands je suis tombé je me bats non
on est dos la divine monnaye y est les
bons emplois détruits au virus ebola
comment détruire le mollah en trois gros
de ces partis aux huiles et f cas là où
vous voyez c'est une technique qui
l'attend en fait est d'ailleurs le
premier à repérer au récit starmer
oh non si j'étais assez gros pour le
mans janak vite vite vite vite vite vite
vite non hall [ __ ] italie comment la
germanie fut vaincue bon ok c'est
reparti mimi watts
non mais mais mais c'est chez pourquoi
on glisse et pour couronner le tout les
filles à poil là bon j'avoue je craque
aller contre moi allez je veux la voir
cette fille là allaient se dégage pour
avoir cette raie manta pour une
entreprise de faire ça voilà donc ip
pour une vidéo tu veux pas faut-il cas
deviendra grand à force de manger de
mécréants
hop là hop là haut
c'est dommage bien là la magie 556 tu
vas me lâche et bellagraâ non j'étais
attirée pas en plus car une pub pour un
top mais a pu le linge étendu donc
émergent biais de supputations autour
voir ça lui c'est le première lui
j'annonce s'appelle na c'est pourquoi
ils s'appellent nobs qui les fans de mac
les morts nana na na nana na na 25e tout
va bien non les playes il ne sait plus
quoi faire
il ne sait plus quoi fait depuis
longtemps on tombe bien bas oh il est
caché je vais avec lui bonjour je ferai
plus de cache-cache de toute ma vie elle
met tous batman je suis robin là ok
façon batman il a toujours survécu robin
site ont pris une petite claque comme ça
voila voila encore comme ça là au jeu au
milieu des titans mec nord là là il va
ce split est ce que c'est un hors la loi
jack veut notre zizi bien désolé il veut
mais il m'aura pas voilà m haies a pas
eu cette dja qui m'a eu et moi je reste
calme quand c'est comme ça tu 4g avoué
je suis caps coup zz c'est drôle ça
wimbledon se doper simili c'est parfait
le désespoir dans son regard était
intense squeeze ai rêvé d'être grand
très grand aux [ __ ] à montgaillard du
titan on peut passer ou pas ces instants
où l instant pas que tu manges mais
n'entend lui c'est le mien c'est de
l'enseignant et ses com
ça que la carrière de squeeze pris fin
on se réveille on prend tous leurs
baisers leur voix
[Musique]
6 2 6 2 qu'est-ce qu'ils fassent
tussauds reçues il sort sur et voilà
doit bien tu te split pas ou je te baise
voilà tu te speed pas ou je te baise
partie on va manger un kaka on va manger
un kaka a plutôt il a mangé sahel à
manger de bonnes grosses merdes plutôt
là si j'avais su qu'il allait arriver
plus tôt at on pas dans arrête arrête
mon grand frère il fait du ping pong
depuis le début du mois et coûté choix
concert premiers sur la grille au ipad
dans cent mille années je vous laisse
tous c'était convaincant vous savez ce
que c'est notre fierté aujourd'hui c'est
pas d'être 68e dans la game non non non
c'est d'avoir réussi à battre et
bollaert à exterminer un virus
aujourd'hui
allez je tente pour la barre il est très
malin oh oui lui donnent plus ils à nous
mais qu il est mort
ou deux mais je savais que la voie
détournée aux mondiaux nature
découvertes hier 11e on pèse auquel on a
eu 2 est content alors là je suis
vraiment une merde voilà voilà voilà et
c'est la bouffe mois fois bout c'est ce
qui est pire que de passer 2 11e à mort
d'un gars you vouloir prendre sa
revanche est tombé sur une pub pour un
perroquet qui al khor de poséidon ça
c'est la vraie déprime c'est le dernier
arrêt c'est avant la fin hop là merci et
nous veut et nous venons non non non je
pouvais pas lire ton pseudo je sais pas
lire cette langue n'est en tout cas
tenter la ya une brochette à fermer oh
c'est bon ça 9e on est dans classement
ce offishal classe madoff pro game
[Musique]
8 ya moyen on prend le temps de gagner
une place en faisant rien c'est bien si
6/5 on est bien on est quatrièmes on a
encore gagné deux places qu'est ce qui
nous arrive aujourd'hui sur ipad au
royal premier en dessous s'te plaît pb
oui bah voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin
de cette vidéo sur ce [ __ ] des landes
jeu de merde t'es à garges ce super jeu
très agréable vraiment voilà je suis
content d'avoir fait une vidéo tu
m'aimes ça s'est très mal passé comme
très souvent finalement voilà signer la
pétition dont la description pour plus
qu'on puisse splitté sur un chariot bon
bah écoute insu retour très bientôt dans
une prochaine vidéo je vais me remettre
de mes émotions puisque ma tête a quand
même explosé pas l'oublier portez vous
bien le chat le monde bis
[Musique]
oh